[Music]
this is a call from a debt collector
please consider donating to veterans of
America we are calling you from the
investigation team of IRS do these kinds
of robo calls sound familiar how about
just plain annoying if you live in the
US the answer is probably yes
one robo calling app found that there
were 26 point three billion unwanted
robo calls made to us mobile phones in
2018 and another blocking app put that
number much higher estimating that there
were nearly 48 billion but these calls
aren't just annoying they're also
costing US citizens a lot of money
scamming them out of nine point five
billion dollars in 2017 so why can't the
FCC and Federal Trade Commission stop
them well it's not that simple robo
calls are nearly impossible to stop
here's why the Internet has made it
easier and cheaper for Robo callers in
pre-internet days phone calls were
transmitted over a landline from caller
a 2 receiver B but now through a simple
click of a button on their computer a
robo caller can call tens of thousands
of phones simultaneously on top of that
they can obscure the origin of their
calls for example a robo caller and a
country overseas can legally buy US
phone numbers and use those numbers to
make their calls their goal is to trick
recipients into thinking they're
receiving a call from the US
internet-based voice systems allows
scammers overseas to operate cheaply and
more easily to make millions of robo
calls from abroad the FCC has ordered
cell phone carriers make sure every call
that's initiated makes it through to the
receiver the point of this was in part
to prevent the carriers from neglecting
customers in rural areas where service
can be dodgy but because of these
mandates carriers are wary of blocking
suspected Robo callers out of fear of
violating these rules to help fix this
problem the FCC in 2017 adopted specific
rules that give carriers the ability to
block calls that are coming from
obviously invalid numbers for example
they can now block calls that don't
contain the right number of digits
numbers that
single digit repeated numbers that are
coming from a fake area code and more
but even with these new rules illegal
calls continue some scammers use
sophisticated tactics to hide their
identity such as spoofing for example a
call may look like it's coming from an
area code close to where the recipient
lives in order to encourage them to
answer regulators have brought hefty
fines in recent years to punish Robo
callers in an effort to regain
ill-gotten assets look at this chart it
shows the difference between how much
the FCC has ordered wrongdoers to pay
versus how much the government has
actually collected that's 208 million
dollars versus $7,000 it has to rely on
the Justice Department to collect the
fines and issues the FTC has at a
similar experience the total it's
secured in court judgments for cases
involving the violations in this chart
plus the amount requested to pay back to
wronged consumers is 1.5 billion dollars
since 2004 but so far it's only
collected 121 million dollars in May of
2018
the FCC find a florida-based company and
its top executive 120 million dollars
for making a hundred million illegal
robocalls in 2016 but agency records as
of late December indicate that no funds
had been collected one reason for the
difficulty in holding Robo callers
accountable is that they're often very
small operations that are unable to pay
the full penalties according to
enforcement officials these operations
can quickly close up shop and change
their names or hide their assets
another reason robo calls are unlikely
to disappear is that many are actually
legal and useful for the recipient this
is a courtesy call to let you know your
prescription order is ready for pickup
according to a 2018 study more than 60%
of robo calls were legitimate calls like
telemarketers reminders and alerts and
that's what's tricky there's a
difference between unwanted and illegal
you may not want to hear from a debt
collector but they may have the right to
call you because of Terms of Service
you've signed further complicating
things is that the call centers are
number sellers hired for legitimate
purposes can also be used by scammers
this makes it difficult for carriers to
distinguish between legal and illegal
robocalling
finally many Robo callers aren't
actually calling you from the US this
makes it even harder for authorities to
hold illegal robocallers accountable if
a robo caller is calling the u.s. from
another country it's difficult for
government officials to identify bad
actors and even when they are able to
identify the robo caller they may not
have the jurisdiction to punish them in
response to these problems the FCC has
demanded that the telecommunications
industry develop solutions to help stop
robo calls and spoof calling numbers the
industry has since come up with stir and
shaken to protocols that help verify
whether the phone number of a caller is
legitimate once deployed call recipients
will have a symbol pop up on their phone
that indicates whether the caller is
legitimate but even those systems won't
stop all robo calls they'll simply
signal when a call has been verified
that means your phone will still ring
when an illegal robocallers is trying to
reach you
[Music]